today we're going to be speaking with
steve kaufman who's a former canadian
diplomat and business executive who
spent the last 16 years learning
languages and encouraging others to do
so with his youtube channel lingo steve
and
lingq.com an app that he co-founded us
it's really great to talk to you i
appreciate you being on
glad to be here so okay i mean let's
let's orient the audience a little bit
uh you you speak about 20 languages is
that correct
right let's say
a dozen or so that i could easily get
into a conversation and hold up my end
and another you know eight or so that
i'm in various stages of having
forgotten or learning uh
but i put a lot of effort into so there
are all of these kind of conventional
wisdoms about language learning
including um
after a certain age the ability to learn
a language in a way that would be
close to close to native uh becomes
dramatically diminished oftentimes
people talk about age 10 11 or 12 or
something like that
the another idea about the best way to
learn languages whether it's by
immersion or with certain types of
programs or whatever the case may be
what can we definitively say about
learning language learning abilities in
humans
well you know i'm not an expert on that
but i think
the goal of learning to speak like a
native in other words to be
indistinguishable from a native is very
difficult past the age of say 10 11.
we've all experienced i mean if you have
an immigrant in the us or canada that
came before the age of 12 very likely
they'll end up speaking like a native if
they arrive after the age of 20 they'll
speak very very well they may have a
large vocabulary they may express
themselves better than natives but you
will always detect a little something
there that gives them away so the goal
isn't to speak like a native
in my case sure yeah and in fact many
people don't know that i am not a native
english speaker i actually learned
english i mean i kind of am i learned
english at age six when i moved to the
united states from argentina right um
can you talk a little bit about
the in terms of the techniques you've
found effective for learning new
languages what are they
right so the language has to come from
outside
uh so you can't begin speaking you have
to listen a lot we listen as children
as a six i came from sweden at the age
of five
you hear other people speaking you pick
up on it eventually you start imitating
it you start speaking with mistakes and
eventually you make fewer mistakes
so to me input is the key lots of
listening and reading and at some point
the brain has gotten used to the
language now and and wants to output
wants to say things and we'll say them
wrong but eventually we'll start saying
them right and it's not because other
people correct them we start to hear it
better and better we become aware of our
own shortcomings or gaps and we
self-correct
sure you can correct it has some input
so to that extent traditional language
instruction which focuses on getting you
to speak early and speak correctly early
has it backwards you have to begin by
exposing yourself to a lot of the
language in situations that are
meaningful to you and gradually you will
get better and you'll speak more and as
you speak more you'll speak better but
you know it's not that instruction is
bad
or grammar instruction but it's not
necessary
there are the i don't want to call them
gimmicks but there are lots of programs
that are predicated on the idea of
if you can um uh first learn to sum to
hear and and learn and practice saying
sort of like 20
relatively common words and phrases and
then expand that to like a hundred and
that will kind of really place you not
only in terms of vocabulary and some of
the most commonly used words but the the
syntax of the grammar of a language that
that's one of the best ways to start by
taking those specific phrases and words
and looking at that first in whatever
language you're trying to learn does
that sound like a reasonable technique
to you
not at all
but i saw where
i can't remember his name but he had the
four hours work week or something and he
was saying he once you deconstruct the
language you understand how it works i
don't believe that because first of all
anything you learn in the language
you're going to forget so if you learn
them all a certain 20 phrases you're
going to keep on forgetting them anyway
those very common words and phrases are
going to come up if you're listening and
reading and allowing your brain to get
used to the language the very common
words and phrases are going to come up
you can't sort of isolate them and learn
them you have to learn them as part of
allowing your brain to get used to the
language
some of the sort of structural aspects
okay the verb comes at the end that's
gonna become pretty obvious to you
you're gonna get used to it and the idea
of learning a few phrases i mean i've
tried it uh when i say i went to a
country where i didn't speak the
language like vietnam i got a phrase
book i tried to learn the phrases
hopeless you just can't it's a gradual
process of of absorbing it's kind of
like a snowball getting larger and
larger as it rolls down the hill you
can't just isolate a few things and
learn them i don't believe that
it would seem intuitive and obvious that
languages that are
more similar to those that we speak are
the easiest to learn i mean for example
uh i
my french is pretty okay and i could
tell when i was in french class in high
school that i had a much easier time
because i spoke spanish so much of
french is similar to spanish when i go
to italy or portugal
i can just speak spanish to a lot of
people and they speak their language to
me we understand each other because the
languages are similar on the other hand
i've tried to learn hebrew
and it's extraordinarily difficult it's
it's a different alphabet it's written
from right to left the the syntax of the
grammar is completely different is that
always the case just that the closer the
language is to what you speak the easier
it is
always the case
the biggest issue in learning languages
is words vocabulary so if you're going
from spanish to portuguese you've got 95
of the vocabulary with french you've got
90 or whatever the number is yeah
english to spanish you got 50 of the
vocabulary because of the common latin
origin of so much vocabulary so common
vocabulary is the biggest
because language learning is about
learning words if we have a lot of words
we the brain starts to figure out how
the language works but it's the words
that we need to have the other thing is
writing system obviously if it's written
in the latin alphabet i mean i've
learned you know chinese japanese arabic
persian now hebrew i tried to i mean
where the korean where the language
where the writing system is different
it's a lot more difficult because
everything is habit and we're so used to
reading in our own alphabet and even if
we understand how the symbols work in
hebrew
um
until our brain really gets used to
reading in that language it takes me you
got to read millions of words so yes
familia similarity of of vocabulary and
obviously the same writing system going
to make it a lot easier are there
objectively
more difficult languages to learn
regardless from what language you're
coming from in other words i i think
like one question would be if you speak
english what are the easiest languages
to learn that's one question but but a
more another question would be are there
just objectively more difficult
languages
well i'll give you a good example for an
english speaker as i am i find slavic
languages complicated in their grammar
but if you are a speaker of a sli if
you're a polish speaker and you want to
learn you know ukrainian it's not
difficult
because you're already used to that so
the the issue is how different are the
patterns and the words of that language
compared to languages you already know
uh to me that's uh to try to say okay i
mean right now i'm learning persian and
arabic arabic is more and so they're
both foreign to me arabic is more
complicated arabic is more difficult
it's objectively more difficult than
persian
but it might be because persian is an
indo-european language which arabic is
not they both use the same writing
system
language sorry no no i was going to say
when you
when you start with a different writing
system like those
do you go directly to the written
language or do you not even worry about
that initially and just start with
listening to it and trying to speak
well i always start listening and when i
listen i can't understand obviously it's
just noise so then i start reading
but i read small amounts in the case of
arabic and persian i go straight into
the writing system with chinese where
this the writing system is not phonetic
then i did spend sort of one month
listening and reading in a phonetic you
know opinion or the sort of
romanization of of the chinese
so that when i went to start learning
the characters at least i had some sense
of the language and the words but that's
the only case where i've done that
otherwise i go straight in if it's a
phonetic script you know korean uh
japanese to some extent uh and certainly
arabic and persian i i i know up front
that it's gonna take me a long time to
get used to it so i i look at very short
like on link we have the ability to look
at sentence by sentence so i listen to
the sentence i look at it i read it i
don't remember what that symbol is i
look up the symbol i read it again
everything about language learning is
what seems initially impossible you'll
never get there you'll never understand
if you just keep on putting in the time
you eventually get there so you know
persian in arabic at first it's just
noise and a bunch of squigglies
but if you just stay with it the brain
it's got to trust your brain you're
going to trust your brain your brain
will get used to it
i don't know how much you know about how
language is taught
in the united states in general in
middle school and high school but one of
the things i've observed is that many of
the people who take a few years of a
second language in the united states
don't really come out speaking very much
at all and some of the things i observed
in my high school for example with the
spanish teachers was
many of them were not only non-native
speakers they weren't even really fluent
they spoke with with very poor accents
and grammatically it was like 90 percent
of the way there so okay that seems to
me like a recipe for disaster if the
person teaching doesn't speak that well
it's going to be hard to learn but can
you comment a little bit about how
language is taught to middle and high
schoolers and and whether it's being
done the right way or not
well and even a worse example is the
english school system in canada where
kids have
english for excuse me have french for
let's say 10 years and can't speak ah
and
the thing is that first of all
motivation and the attitude of the
learner is so important so the most
important thing for the teacher is to be
able to motivate the learner we don't
need the teacher to become the model of
the language particularly today there's
so much stuff out there
there's some there's
netflix and youtube and podcasts and
radio and tv we don't need the teacher
to be the model of the language but the
teacher has to motivate the learner you
don't even really need the teacher to
teach the grammar you can look it up if
i want to know the conjugation of a verb
in spanish i can look it up if i'm
curious if i'm motivated so the key
thing is motivation and that's where the
way languages are taught typically is
quite demotivating because you're taught
some rules of grammar you're tested on
it you get it wrong
getting things wrong is not very
motivating if you can spend the time
listening to things of interest to you
reading
getting the language in you
more more students will learn to speak
well some some students don't want to
learn but it's the whole idea can you
increase the number of people who are
motivated enough to learn that they will
actually go out and learn
last thing i want to ask you about very
anecdotally
i'm curious whether
there is a linguistic or societal
explanation for why some folks seem to
be almost like predisposed to better
learn
some languages like english and i'll
give you an example i've this is very
anecdotal and i'm going to you just for
you to tell me it's only anecdotal or
there's something to it i've met a
number of folks from the philippines
when i was in france when i was in the
uk
who
spoke english as though they were native
american individuals and they told me
i've never even been to the united
states i learned english merely by
watching american films and television
shows and kind of teaching myself and to
me they sounded like native american
english speakers is there something for
example about the filipino language or
the people that might predispose them to
be better at learning english is there
something to that
i don't think so i mean we have a lot of
filipino immigrants here in vancouver
and a lot of them speak with a
noticeable accent which they never get
rid of
it's rather the the access to american
tv programs if you go to sweden
everyone speaks english it's not because
they teach english better in their
schools it's because all television
programs are in the original version so
they watch lots of american and british
television it's kind of natural to them
that's part of almost part of the
culture they grow up with so
again it comes back to input
uh you know if you're uh if you're an
english-speaking canadian in vancouver
you never watch anything in french
unless you're going to the french
immersion program
the school system is not going to do
much right for you they're going to
teach you a bunch of rules you won't
have anything at the end of it so
it all comes back to
input i mean and people do learn who who
aren't uh you know in in the country
when they on television watching these
uh i'm amazed at these ukrainians you
know that are on tv a lot and they're
being interviewed and their english is
unbelievable yeah and they haven't been
living in the states so if a person is
motivated if a person spends time
listening to the language reading in the
language
much more that's much more important
than any classroom activity
we've been speaking with steve kaufman
you can find his youtube channel at
lingo steve and also the language
learning app that he co-founded at
lingq.com that's lingq.com
steve such a pleasure having you on
today i really appreciate it
i could talk forever on languages